What is going on?
Shhh....it’s the trade deadline
This could be our ticket out of here
Why would you want to leave?
Aren’t we in line for the first pick?
No, we’re not!
Because that fool Billy King traded it to
Boston a few years ago!
What!?
I know! They’re idiots--
Der coming! Der coming!
Back up, back up!
Everybody back up!
I’m sorry to announce...
we have made a trade
Oh yes oh yes
Please please please
Bojan
Yeah
You’re going to Washingfell
Sorry
Oh my god!
They are like, uh...
They have like...wins
Yes
Thirty-four wins, they have
THIRTY-FOUR?!
Oh man, that’s like so many wins!
I know you’re disappointed, but...
pack your bags
They expect you there on the morrow
Right. Right. Oh yeah I’m very sad
This is so--I’m very sad but I’ll go pack now
and fight all the tears
Um...love all you guys!
Thanks, uh, Lord Commander--ex-Lord Commander!
Oh this is so sad!
This is SO GOOD! OH I’M FREE!
I’M FREE FROM THIS PIECE OF SHIT TEAM!
THIS IS THE HAPPIEST DAY OF MY LIFE!
I DON’T HAVE TO BE IN STUPID BROOKLYN
THIS IS THE DUMBEST PLACE
WORST FRANCHISE  EVER!
MAN THESE GUYS ARE F--
Any..uh...other trades to report? Or...
No
Dammit!
Now, come on, it's time to practice
Tomorrow we lose to the Nuggets!
Who goes there?
House Magic!
What are they doing here?
We don’t play ‘em for a fortnight
What do you want?
We want to propose a trade!
Well we don’t need a trade.
We’re contenders!
Oh come on now, you’re fifth in the East!
You’re worse than the...Hawks right now!
Don’t you want to compete with the Cavs?
I mean, It’s true
We could use, like, a power forward
Well then do it! Do it! Do it!
Well alright, whaddya got?
Serge Ibaka!
He shoots, dunks, and he’s an elite rim protector.
He’s everything you need
Isn’t that right Serge?
I defend anyone
Except LeBron
Alright. Okay
Well what do you want for him?
DeMar DeRozan!
No! He’s my friend!
Argh. Very well
Worth a shot
Then give us...
Norman Powell!
No!
He's...too young!
But I’m also your friend, right?
Shush Norman!
I'm trying to make a trade here!
I am also his friend!
Norman!
Alright. Well then what else do you have to offer?
We’ll give you...
Can we trade Drake?
I don’t think so. No
What about Terrence?
What about Terr--
You can have Terrence Ross
Well what does he do?
He’s like...
an older Norman
No I’m not
Terrence! You’ll like it in Orlando. It’s warm
Let the man speak!
Terrence, what do you do?
Well, I’m a pretty good 3 and D player...
Um...
though some people might call me inconsistent...
So maybe I’m not a good 3 and D player--
No no no, you are!
I AM a good 3 and D player
OH! And a decorated dunker!
Well he’s certainly inconsistent
Throw in a draft pick and it’s a deal!
A draft pi--
Fine, but then you gotta give us somethin’ else too!
Something else? Ugh
Alright we’ll give you a choice
You can either have...Mario Hezonja...
Or...this horse
Well what does Mario do?
He scores three points a game
And what does the horse do?
It’s a f-- it’s a horse!
It walks around with people on it
I don’t know...does horse things!
That kid was the fifth pick in the draft.  He's probably got potential.
Yeah but it's a horse! It does horse things!
We’ll take the horse!